We seemed to have arrived at the moment
of truth for our entrepreneurs.
They've gotta pick a model to implement.
Do you have any suggestions, Ito?
>> Sure.
In many cases,
the choice is pretty clear.
For example,
most games are using a framing model and
such, generally using subscriptions.
Both benefits from the trust
they created with their users.
However, there is no
replacement to keep trying and
tuning the models that
fit your special needs.
There are rare cases where
you have enough funding and
you wish to focus on growth.
It's totally fine, since the value
of your company is composed
from the current revenue stream and
the future one.
>> Let's also hear from some other
startups to get their advise on
choosing a monetization strategy.